toujours sur le stand de Peugeot mais on
s'attaque cette fois-ci à la partie du
rêve le rêve que vend peugeot sur ce
salon de l'automobile dans ce véhicule
l'onyix bonsoir donc à Sophie Gazo vous
êtes stylist couleur et matier vous
travaillez à l'ADN c'est là où se
fabrique un petit peu tout du côté de de
Peugeot c'est sur Vézy vous avez
travaillé sur ce véhicule voilà là-bas à
véis vous AZ travailler sur quoi alors
moi je suis en charge de de toutes les
couleurs et matières en fait du véhicule
donc surt les ASP
intérieur extérieur sur ce projet sur ce
projet mais aussi sur le le concept
scooter et le concept bike voilà qu'on
aperçoit effectivement c'est décliné sur
trois trois véhicules trois types de
véhicules là donc concrètement c'est du
concept voilà c'est une voiture c'est
une super car mais c'est un concept donc
c'est une voiture de rêve on est allé
très loin sur ce concept on a
expérimenté des matériaux qui sont assez
surprenants mais en même temps qui ne
sont pas étrangers au monde de
l'automobile on a été très loin et ça
donne un résultat dont on est plutôt
fier et et voilà quelles sont les choses
inédites un petit peu qu'on retrouve sur
ce véhicule sur lesquels vous avez
travaillé alors on a déjà du du cuivre
sur l'extérieur donc ça on le voit on
l'assume le le cuivre c'est sur
l'extérieur mais le cuivre n'est pas
forcément une étranger à l'automobile
puisque on on a dans une voiture de
série à peu près quarantaine de kilos de
de cuivre en couponsant puisque le
cuivre est très conducteur donc le
cuivre ici on l'a assumé on l'a mis sur
l'extérieur parce que c'est un matériau
qui va évoluer dans le temps qui va
remarquablement changer qui va c'est une
voiture qui pourrait évoler dans le
temps voilà qu'est-ce qu'on attend d'yx
en fait on attend que elle vive on
attend de voir dans 2 ans son aspect
puisque en fait on on aime aussi le le
cuivre dans son aspect vieilli on aime
le cuivre patiné donc on l'a pas protégé
en fait de de vernis on n pas on n pas
mis de lac pardessus c'est vraiment une
approche très naturelle en fait des
matériaux très bruts et on pourrait
imaginer la même chose sur des véhicules
de série alors sur les véhicules de
série on pourrait imaginer une autre
application du cuivre celle qu'on a mis
en fait sur les scooters et sur les
vélos c'est en fait une une
pulvérisation de cuivre donc ce serait
des un voile de Micron en fait donc
c'est une très fine épaisseur mais en
fait du coup c'est beaucoup plus léger
ça a l'aspect du cuivre mais c'est
beaucoup plus léger que le cuivre donc
là on est sur l'aspect extérieur du
véhicule à l'intérieur qui son même
chose des choses un petit peu
inéditesintur voilà à l'intérieur on a
des choses inédites alors on a trois
choses inédite on a du feutre on a du
newspaper Wood et on a du cristal alors
je vais commencer par le feutre parce
que déjà il a été fait chez nous à l'ADN
donc ça on en est très fier en fait à
l'ADN on a une on a on a une sellerlerie
on a nos sellliers en fait et qui
travaillent en on travaille en
collaboration avec eux il nous aideent à
développer des concepts et là l'idée
c'était l'idée c'était une boîte à œuf
en fait l'idée de départ c'était une
boîte à œuf et et donc on a on a voulu
chercher des matériaux qui pouvaient
retranscrire cette idée et le feutre
nous l'a permis nous a permis de faire
ces cette expérimentation puisque le
feutre peut s'appliquer peut-être
détendu ils donc les cellers ont ont
sculpté en fait les volumes avec du
feutre en en un seul morceau et donc on
ne voit aucune découpe dans l'intérieur
en fait et c'était fait exprès c'est
vraiment pour créer un cocon un aspect
de légèreté on le voit sur le pavillon
on le voit aussi à l'intérieur et c'est
une enveloppe en fait très accueillante
voilà après oui une telle voiture
pourrait coûter combien ah ça c'est
impossible on est pas on n pas dans une
approche de de série là on est vraiment
dans un exercice de style donc donc vous
avez carte blanche quand vous travaillez
sur ce type de véhicule on a on a carte
blanche si parce qu'en fait le challenge
sur ce projet c'était pas tellement une
question de budget mais plus une
question de priorité en fait c'est une
supercar elle roule elle va très vite
l'ingénieur qui l'a mis en place me
demander d'avoir des matériaux les plus
légers donc évidemment on a utilisé du
carbone mais moi mon mon rôle c'était
d'avoir un un aspect esthétique optimum
et donc pour ceci on a dû travailler
ensemble à avoir des matériaux les plus
légers mais avec une apparence la plus
la plus qualitative donc c'était c'était
plus ça le le challenge l'échange entre
le poids et l'aspect donc ce véhicule
roule il en existe qu'un seul il est
présenté ici au Salon de l'automobile
merci pour cette présentation de ce
véhicule on va continuer ce tour sur le
salon édition spéciale du 78 consacré au
salon de l'automobile